A pilot crashed his plane in the Sahara desert.
A little prince appeared and asked the pilot to draw him a sheep.
The two became friends.
The pilot learned that the prince was from a small planet called Asteroid 325.
One day, a mysterious rose sprouted and the little prince fell in love with it.
But he lost trust in it when he realized the rose lied to him.
Feeling lonely, he decided to explore other planets.
He passed by many asteroids in his travels.
While traveling, he met a king, a vain man, a drunkard,...
...a businessman, a lamplighter and a geographer.
All lived alone and were extremely busy with their own jobs.
He learned from the geographer that roses do not last forever.
All of a sudden, he began to miss his rose.
At the geographer's suggestion, the little prince visited Earth.
But, he landed in the middle of the desert and could not find any humans.
Instead, he met a snake, talked to a flower and climbed the tallest mountains.
The little prince found a rose garden, which surprised and depressed him.
His rose had told him that she was the only one of her kind.
He made a friend with a fox,...
...who taught him that only the heart can see the important things in life.
The fox also taught that his time away from the rose...
...would make the rose more special to him.
The little prince's mind was fixed on returning to his rose.
He began making plans with the snake to go back to his planet.
But the snake bit the prince and he fell noiselessly to the sand.
The next day, the pilot could not find the prince's body.
He wondered if the little prince ever returned to his asteroid.